who will join the leader leaders group
exactly yeah we just saw this move F4 by
Sam Sevilla what's going on here
looks like uh uh they're talking oh
maybe a draw they're talking okay make a
draw
somehow they want to they're discussing
something I hope they are discussing
something what's what's happening
something happened what's going on in
the current
what just happened yes let's see I see
that Hans is a little bit nervous he's
trying to say something perhaps there's
yes that the Knight is
something happened
yes wow oh you touched your king he's
saying that's your king but wait a
second I mean I mean that's not the
thing with white you know his King is on
the chore
so I'm trying to understand no they
actually went into the operation that uh
you mentioned with Rook taxis yes Rook
text h66 I started to guess moves of
hands you know at the end of the
tournament okay so the the
the Arbiter keeps starting the clock the
players keep stopping the clock
something is confusing yes really don't
know what happened but normally you have
to stop your clock and then you speak to
the Arbiter exactly well in any case uh
Hans is looking at the position after F4
now that was the line that we looked at
Anastasia is it a draw
um Christian I mean the the line we
looked at was pretty yes even yes yes
father said about it long time ago guys
it's a draw I don't want the one to
calculate
B3 F6 I was trying to maintain The Rook
on the uh
so this is so right now he's Sam's sorry
it's hans's move yes let's see what
happened yes and then
what whoa
King
and he broke and he broke that
yeah
I cannot believe what just happened oh
my God he just broke the king for some
reason and he put it back and now he's
telling him let's go outside and what is
this
that is hilarious I've never seen that
now he's trying to put the baby keep him
under the table is is that what happened
I mean definitely upset about it
this is amazing
this is amazing I've never seen
something like this no never never in my
life okay
unbelievable okay many players they have
this Habit to turn the piece right
around a bad terrible terrible I tried
to imagine that perhaps he just wanted
to take one if you did that you would be
shocked right but he was actually
motioning like let's go outside let's go
outside and and do what else but the
crazy part was that when when uh excuse
me dude you're you're fiddling with my
king dude let's see again then Sam kind
of threw the king to B6 look at his
hands yes right now
and the cross has fallen out of the
king's side and then he's kind of just
threw the king to peace exit like what
let's go outside let's go outside
no he's got the cross in his hand and
he's like fiddling oh my goodness dude
what is happening I don't know but
somehow
oh that is I've never seen that that's
kind of funny
okay we need an explanation I I hope
after the end of this game we'll we'll
have it I hope I mean I mean his eyes I
think the few committees on the way to
start working right finally finally the
appeals committee has something
something must have happened between
these two guys when we were not watching
because they seemed distressed both of
them I I don't know what happened but it
seems like the nerves the nerves the
players are they seem to be a little bit
on the edge yeah they are they
definitely are you know and by the way
Sam uh sorry uh Hans just took on B2 to
the pawn
after all of that give me my king I mean
thank you let me take your bond with my
king king takes B2 oh my goodness so my
explanation is that Sam wanted to pick
up a piece off the board so he could
twiddle with it and somehow his King he
picked up the piece on the board why do
you think the crows did well then it
popped out I don't know what happened
with with that but that was pretty
uh unusual I've never seen it actually
never ever actually what kind of penalty
can be for this type of yeah
take the king of your opponent like it's
almost an illegal move so I'm gonna
penalize you with an illegal move by
saying you know you did something that
you can't do you can't and I'll give you
I'm gonna give your opponent a reward
them with two minutes for bad
misbehavior but I have never seen this
one more look at what we just saw
because again this is unprecedented we
cannot see his little face right yes we
cannot see his whole face is that
correct I mean because I would love to
see his face right now
I'm thinking it's my turn you just
picked up my age
actually
right it's kind of a flipping thing to
do and is asking like what what's wrong
like why do you why did you do this why
are you misbehaving the disrespectful
U.S championships are continued or
something happening there's something in
the water man
in the same same vein as when we started
and then he puts it back in well that
was very kind right I mean he he
repaired the king
that was kind it keeps touching the
kingdom and Hans is like dude man you
can't do it I mean leave my kingdom the
first impressive thing they just keep
doing it
like nothing happened wow that's why
sometimes you need to have this press
conferences with two players you never
know the press conference so you get you
get the double uh opinion right right
right right right
just on that note I remember the press
conference in the world championship in
New York
um Magnus had lost ah so we have also
faces
so he's stolen the king and now
that's the king Seb and